-Real quick --
obviously as I've announced,
we're gonna have a second child.
It's gonna be a son.
Dad, what do you think?
Two? Keep going? Stop?
-My philosophy was
two hands, two kids.
-That's it?
-That was it.
-If you can't handle more...
-No. That was the most
I could handle.
-Okay, gotcha.
I think you did
a really good job.
-I thought so, too.
[ Laughter ]
-All right, guys,
we cleared the air,
but there was something --
I want to say
it was about 10 years ago now
that was a genuine
clearing the air
that sort of happened
at a dinner
where it was just
the four of us.
First, let's talk about
Petey the Rabbit.
Who would like to explain what
kind of rabbit Petey was?
-Well, it was Poshy's rabbit,
so he should start.
-Petey was a girl, but my father
had a pet -- not a pet --
-A stuffed animal.
-Rabbit named Petey
when he was growing up,
and he talked about it a lot,
which was weird.
-Yes.
[ Laughter ]
-So I got a rabbit,
and I named her Petey.
And rabbits smell terribly.
-Yeah.
-In their little hutches.
So we kept her in a hutch
in the garage.
We'd bring her out and she'd
bounce around the house
and always try to run away
'cause that's what
she wanted to do.
But I loved her.
-Yeah.
So how old were you
on the fateful day?
-I don't -- I don't know.
-I think -- I think maybe 7.
And he was 9.
-Okay.
-You were 9.
-Yeah, something like that.
-So what happened was, Poshy
came upstairs and he said,
"Petey's in the cutest position.
You've got to come down
and see him."
So I went down.
And the position
was rigor mortis.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Hold that.
This was the position.
[ Laughter ]
-So, this one, this one says to
Seth, "Take Seth away and..."
-I can tell you.
He says to me, "I feel weird
around dead things."
-Right. And he thinks
you're fine with it.
-Yeah.
-Because you would
touch anything.
-That's true, but...
I feel like you were encouraging
me to be a serial killer.
Because you said, "I'm weird
with dead things.
You have to go bury Petey."
Again, I was 9.
-Right.
And they don't call
New Hampshire
The Granite State for nothing.
-And it was the winter.
-And it was January,
and it was about 20 below zero.
-Also, so, Josh was crying.
You guys gave me a shoe box
and told me to go bury Petey.
Based on the rigor mortis,
there was no way of getting
Petey's legs into the box.
-That's a technicality.
-Technicality.
-But first,
before we know any of that,
there's a rock that you put down
as a headstone,
and we go out
and we have a ceremony.
-Yes. So, I say --
I say Petey is buried, I put a
rock, a headstone, we come out.
-And it was like in like a trail
where we would always sled,
and we'd always have to
build up a snow bank
so we didn't go
over Petey's grave.
And Mom would walk by it.
And then we're at this dinner
and you're like...
-Yeah, like 15 years later,
and we're drinking,
we're having a fun time,
we're laughing about the past.
And I say, "Hey, guys, do you
want to hear something funny?
I didn't bury Petey.
I threw Petey in the garbage."
[ Laughter ]
-This is a real dagger.
-It was so --
I thought everybody
would burst out laughing
and nobody did at all.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, it was daggers.
-It was daggers, yeah.
-Oh, there was -- Yeah.
-You couldn't get the shovel
into the ground.
-No, that was the thing.
I was 9 years old,
it was freezing,
and I couldn't get any dirt up,
and all I could think was
all Petey ever wanted to do
was run away.
The worst thing to do would be
bury her on the property.
-That is true.
-I put her in a truck,
and I said, "Go, Petey."
[ Laughter ]
-But I thought about this
for 20 years
when I had to go
from one point to another.
I would have to
walk around that rock.
And I've felt so stupid.
I didn't feel stupid
asking you to bury it
when you were 9 years old
in frozen granite ground
in New Hampshire.
But I did feel stupid
walking around that rock
for 20 years.
-Well, thank you, guys,
for forgiving me for that.
Hey, to Petey. Drink to Petey.